aus mannheim ist uns nämlich jetzt
comedian oliver pocher und olli ist dort
nicht ganz alleine hat glaube ich ein
paar freunde
beschränken
[Applaus]
die leute mit uns hat sich so im
politisch aktiv werden kann
die sogenannte korona show und wir haben
natürlich auch schon über einige
diskutiert über die wahrheit gibt es
anschließend zum beispiel dass man in
die innstadt reinfeldt die
ausgeschriebene verliert ein thema aus
dem politischen ändern sollten aber
bitte eure frage wir haben hier alle
pocher diskutiert über armin laschet der
den wahlzettel so ganz offensichtlich
und überhaupt nicht geheim in die urne
gesteckt hat war das absicht oder war
das einfach nur toll partie
das war einfach nur dumm
[Applaus]
er hat wenigstens
nicht gut gemacht als es darüber aber
ganz praktisch ist diese stimmung
möglich also dass auch makel kaschieren
eigentlich das noch nicht mal cdu - aber
ist ja ganz interessant was man so von
den umfragen wird wird es trotzdem ein
großes comeback team von armin laschet
und das trotzdem nicht wirklich man
denkt sich auch immer noch niemand
wählen kann auch richtig gab jetzt gibt
es noch eine zweite riesengeschichte
heute an diesem wahltag nämlich
wahlchaos in berlin man hat heute
überrascht festgestellt dass die wahl
zusammen fällt mit dem berlin marathon
also man gleich zwei großereignisse in
einer stadt hat und jetzt kommt man mit
dem stimmzettel nachschub nicht richtig
hinterher oli pocher
das ist auch reichlich dämlich ehrlich
gesagt wenn wir aber ich habe noch
keinen gesehen der behauptete sogar
verstehen wollte aber es ist es ist es
ist es fast ein bisschen nach berlin ich
glaube die studie zu kaufen ausgezählt
werden und wir können davon ausgehen
dass
2028 auch bestimmt fertig sind und
solange für rot-rot gewöhnen mit einem
kind das alles nur noch 500 euro da
weiter regieren aber ist natürlich darf
nicht passieren dürfen
letzte frage olli bevor es wieder mit
lustigeren themen bei dir gleich
weitergeht was glaubst du wie knapp wird
dieses kopf-an-kopf-rennen wann werden
wir wissen wer der zukünftige kandler
wer kanzler von deutschland ist
ein gut also wissen werden wir natürlich
alle stimmen ausgezählt sind aber
jemanden so hört ist es wirklich geht es
zwischen cdu und spd sehen die grünen
haben erstaunlich deutlich jetzt
absteigers oder redet man ja von bis zu
18 prozent abiturienten nachgesehen und
wo ich viele leute vor angst hat dass
man einfach sagen bist du hast hast du
manchmal eine große koalition weiter und
deswegen glaube ich also an die show
noch weiters münster bleibt also dran
gehen kann kann auch noch ein neues
ministerium bleibt also ich glaube dass
müssen jetzt wirklich mal auch ein paar
andere sachen passieren und bitte dich
auf die gruppe am ende einigen
dort in mannheim scholz oder laschet
kann man ganz schnell den klatschen
meter dabei olli pocher in dem wahllokal
anwerfen scholz oder laschet
ihr könnt natürlich darüber gehen das
ist die stimmung die weite was ist das
gesicht wird übel aber wir können warten
meine damen und herren wir werden jetzt
einmal applaudieren falls es nicht
vorstellen könnten kanzler ist jetzt
ihre chance bitte
wahnsinn was bin ich gänsehaut stimmung
hier
das ist dieselbe stimmung also immer
aktuell über günstigere ein schweizer
jetzt will ich bin gespannt jetzt für
die spd ist
der kann sich den herzigen kanzler
vorstellen bitteschön
[Applaus]
die sind mir ich glaube
das hat man natürlich dass alle früheren
olli pocher nicht dass das jetzt falsch
gewichtet ist das erste mal ganz genau
nachher nochmal nach wo da die größeren
ausschläge warten herzlichen dank auf
die bühne dort viel spaß in die show
[Musik]